مسلسل قط احمر عمل درامي كوميدي عراقي
بيتم عرضه للموسم الثاني في رمضان
والمسلسل بيتناول ضمن لوحات كوميديه عن
بيتضمن في هذه اللوحات الكوميديه عدد من
المشاكل في المجتمع مثل الفساد الحكومي
والاداري والتربيه الخاطئه للابناء وغيرها
من المشاكل والعقبات العمل الساعه الماضيه
عامل ضجه كبيره في العراق بسبب احدى
المشاهد اللي طلع فيها الفنان العراقي
احمد وحيد بدور قاضي نشوف المشهد
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله عليك ما شاء الله
على تربيتك رجال شايب لان قال لك هذا غلط
تصيح عليه حلو والله حضرت القاضي انا لا
تجاوزت عليها ولا شي يعني بس انا لان صوتي
عالي يعني ها
حلو هاي عقوبه حلو حلو حلو ما شاء الله
جرائم ولا جرائم
[موسيقى]
اربعه اشهر الدب الزباله بالحاويه وشهرين
ما تقتل زوجتك ما معقول هالشكل يا اخي
شهرين كل ما يخابرونك ترد عقوبتك تمشي
بثلاث معاملات بدون معقد يلا
عقوبتك ما تضرب جهالك سنتين عقوبتك اذا
تشرب بطل ماي ما تشرب من السياره كل اسبوع
تغسل سيارتك
عقوبتك ثلاث اشهر ما تتاخرين عن الدوام
خمس شهور لا تسب ولا تغلط بالتعليقات
عقوبتك ست اشهر ما تسحب على الخاص عقوبتك
يعني احمد طلع في مشهد بيمثل فيه دور قاضي
في مشاهدين شافوا المشهد ولجوا انه في شبه
بين الشخصيه وبين القاضي الراحل محمد
العريبي واللي بيعتبر احد رموز مجلس
القضاء الاعلى في العراق ناس اعتبرت هذا
المشهد سخريه مبطنه من الراحل وفي ناس
اخذت الموضوع اكبر من مجرد رفض وانتقاد
فالموضوع وصل لرفع دعوه قضائيه من احد
المحامين ضد الفنان واعتبر المحامي اللي
صار مو بس اساءه للقاضي محمد العريبي لا
بالاساءه لمجلس القضاء بحد ذاته وطالب
باتخاذ الاجراءات القانونيه اللازمه بحقه
ومن بعدها طلع الفنان احمد وحيد وكتب على
صفحته توضيح قال في انه ما دام الموضوع
وصل للقضاء فالشخصيه اللي قدمها ما لها
علاقه ابدا ولا بيقصد فيها محمد العريبي
وانه نبره الصوت اللي تكلم فيها في المشهد
مو نفس نبره صوت القاضي وحتى تعابير الوجه
وحركات اليدين
مو نفسها فالمرحوم كان هادي جدا بس هو في
المشهد كان مختلف تماما عنه وقال انه
الاهم من هذا الشيء انه القاضي متوفي ومو
من اخلاقه انه يسيء لشخص متوفي
[موسيقى]